the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the title of grand master highly coveted
and sought after since the beginning of
the game
welcome to the third st louis norm
congress
hello and welcome to another day of
wonderful commentary for the norm
congress i am a grandmaster dorothy
darashani and
we have grandmaster
danish boris with us pleased to be here
thank you thank you
um we also have a special guest master
cross song
as french as it gets
yes yes
so
yeah let's talk about what is a norm so
norm is the gold standard of chess in
general terms
norm
is something that you have to achieve
you got to achieve three of those and
then you get the title may it be the
international master title or the grand
master title
we've got plenty of players actually who
have
reached the norm but apart from
having the norms you also have to have
their rating for it so even if you have
three grandmaster norms you still have
to have 2500 at least once in your
lifetime that is true even live i've had
that a bunch of times people cross a lot
but never actually cross it in real
lists but it makes things really
interesting so yeah it's much more
complicated um and it's very
uh jading for some people who are just
new to chess so that's why we always
feel like putting it up for you people
yep
now let's talk about standings so let's
start with the standings in the gm norm
tournaments
so
we got grandmaster
bellows and
he is doing actually quite well yeah
clear first actually played a big match
up
i believe
he played
uh rapco and play and one with black
so um on number two
and it's going to actually be the game
of the day for the grand masters section
is royce castillo
he won against mattvision in an ups and
down and topsy-turvy game
um and of course it actually claimed him
that uh score and he's still playing so
some of you might notice it's three out
of three and the other one
is still could if he wins he could have
clear first then four out of four wow
all right well let's jump in for the i
am norm sections
and
we've got aaron grobinski and three out
of three of course still playing playing
against gabriella antova
and uh marek matthias is second with two
and a half out of three tied with
jennifer you in fact jennifer you had
quite a game against antova
yep i was watching that
i have i have i see quite a few girls
here some of my really close friends
potential current teammates future
teammates
and future yes
could be fun and let's look at the
schedule real quick
um we have
to double around today oh boy double
around tomorrow okay
run around on monday that's nice one one
game at a time on monday so monday 11
a.m round eight
and tuesday
we have one again unless we have a
playoff
that's the good news
uh feel free to definitely join us on
the twitch chat and the youtube chat
give it right here so
we would love to talk to you see how
you're feeling can you answer any
questions
and
with that
let's see
let's go to the grand masters yeah let's
take a look at the preparing for that
yeah yeah
okay
so the pairings so far josiah stearman
one i lost actually not one but lost
against balaji dagupati
um and the rest is still fair game so
joshua ruiz is playing iman shitko
vladimir baloush is playing costa
kavutsky david brodsky is playing the
unlucky matrician and chris rapko plays
against evan park
um let's take a quick look at
oh we got so many good games yeah let's
stay with the ruiz game first
see how that goes
yeah so actually we've been watching
previously like previous stream we've
been
watching ruiz's game and uh he actually
won a topsy-turvy one
and um
yeah if he continues
he might just get in there if i'm wrong
yeah he goes to the utd
yeah i i can't really prove you wrong i
did go too
i just know there's so many of the
collegiate chess players here yes it's a
little hard to keep trying yes i believe
both of them are uh university players
yeah i think i can't remember one of
them my real
tech and the other might be the
dallas but i think i
i might be wrong but i think it should
go as from the rio grande
but that is my take i could be around
you oh well a lot of collegiate players
anyways let's take a look at this
position yes
so
anytime i look at a position i just
can't pause and see
what's going on it looks a fair game to
me
but uh that a2 pawn i feel is a little
bit uh dicey like if that pawn is ever
removed
yeah black is very close to cleaning e3
pawn is very advanced
it would be great if we could get rid of
that
but i can't really see any
clear way
maybe put the bishop maybe white can do
bishop b1 bishop b4 get the king on b3
oh yeah
it may actually walk over there
but it's actually [ __ ] goes moves so
yeah he could either try to go rook e8
try to cut off the king
and making sure that there's no one
passing so there's no passing through
the e file or you could try to go rocket
for rook b4
and try to slide in question uh would it
be better for white
to get rid of these bishops
yeah i think that'd be great for white
because that would mean that there's no
potential bishop b2 i think you were
sort of suggesting bishop to earlier
that kind of over defends the a pawn
and it's very difficult to get to it in
that case so bishop b1 bishop c3 would
definitely favor white yeah i think the
one thing i actually do like about
white's position is that this king can
easily walk up to d3 or b3
and then that's that's a good thing that
wise king can do but black king doesn't
have well
that clear of a path and a while i was
talking the king started moving so yay
yeah so that's a good observation so
what do you think who's who's better
uh
you just go with your heart yeah king
you too was definitely i
okay i feel like if white can get rid of
the bishops and slash or this pawn i
would definitely like white
um
but if black gets to keep this pawn then
i would much
rather be black but i'm also thinking
maybe you know there's a lot of
potential ideas that black can do to
really really bother white
right now it feels like it's being a
little more passive
and white definitely does have less time
so that's another component of it's that
um
you know what i kind of want to be black
right now
why the sudden change of hearts uh i
feel like black would have more chances
um a little bit more aggressive but
whites will need to be
very creative in how to advance this
position
yeah i actually agree like the fact that
the pawn structure is so scattered
like it's on pawn islands
and the fact that the c4 and a2 are weak
means that
black actually has real chances to win
and actually that's why people love
playing the kings indian because you get
all these scattered pawn structures and
by the way have you played the kings and
even ever it's been a while but i did
yeah i've had some really great results
in it but um some reason i just
never really stuck with you just dumped
it yeah i started liking nimso and
queen's camp queens yeah no no no no not
the queen's indian
that was also a little
a lot of different ones girl felt was
something that i really tried and i
really liked but
periodically but all right i definitely
want to take a quick peek at our im
standings and uh pairings because i have
so many good friends there
um
all right well
yeah
so we've got joshua postuma playing
versus pedro rodriguez ezra chambers
already won against julian proleko
we'd actually be happy to see ezra
chambers if he'd be interested to talk
about his game against julian so um if
he's around we'd love to see him that
would be nice uh also i know that julian
is a club teacher favorite but let's
take a quick look at the games game
versus mark
and
oh fun fact um i knew begins since 2000
who got eight really yeah she came she
came to we were both playing in asian
tournaments now we're both playing for
us but she came to iran to play asian
youth under 10 when we were both under
10 and 2008
we played i had a very beautiful game
but i ended up winning but now
well she's she's
slightly stronger right now to be fair
well uh you've been pursuing the
doctorship that is there so um you're
actually you're going for more titles
that's true i am going for more time
more titles so
everyone is picking and choosing their
goals thank you thank you and um now
let's take a look at the game so
um
again
i always look at the pawn structure but
um what is the other thing that would uh
come to your mind to be fair whenever
i'm
teaching because i think so much of
these things i usually tell my kids to
do a head count can't count because you
know sometimes there might be a piece or
two that we're not looking at yeah so
right now
good for us we don't really need to care
about the pieces because they're equal
but pawn structure i mean
i feel like
white spawn structure is a little bit
more
exciting i would say
well i wouldn't use exciting i'd say
damaged
i mean it could also be exciting though
does this this pond and d4 kind of
blocking this bishop's diagonal that's
true so i mean there is pluses and
minuses like the e3
is defending the d4 pawn but look at
that king is actually lacking some
shelter on f2
and um that is a reason for concern for
bagan i feel
yeah but how could black actually use
that
well
that's why i would start considering
some like queen b8
and just try to probe on the king side
even giving up the pawn on a6
would you consider some stuff with e5
anytime soon um definitely that's an
interesting idea let me um
let me see if e5 right now
then taking is a little questionable
just a little bit yeah you just take it
and everything falls yeah just a little
bit yeah what doris is claiming takes
actually it doesn't because the queen is
hanging
but still doesn't still i'm still fine
for black everything it's just kind of
yeah and it's very wobbly for
white i was thinking about the word
wobbly
yeah
nasty check yeah bobby actually brings
up some bad memories from me
not the eric rosen match that i played
it's actually my flight
so i was flying
from france to new york
and i was like
having a very very shaky chair
and i was like oh i'm so sorry someone
behind me was like i'm just telling them
my [ __ ] my chair is so
shaky and then the person in front of me
says a french person this chair
and i was like how come i played a match
against rosen with a wobbly chess set
and this
french guy beats me to it and uses the
verb lee
oh me and i was
like man so uneducated of me
well you made it here in one that's true
i'm happy i'm happy about that thank you
oh yeah yeah well i kind of really want
to take a look at the prize one because
well why not
okay so let's look at the gm section
all right all right total profile price
fund of 9k that's
pretty hefty for norm tournaments played
north tournaments that i had to pay
yeah i mean uh this is very generous
from the st louis chess club thanks
again yeah yeah for the chess club for
putting this up i know you know what i
really like about it is like when you
look even if you end up having a really
bad tournament and you score the last
place you still go home with six hundred
dollars so it's still you know it's
still not
you can still smile a little bit well i
at least earned a little even if i lost
rating points i didn't get the norm
i completely agree and i also want to
add that
whenever you're playing this event um
you are risking something even though
you're the one pursuing the title like
oftentimes you're going there just to
score the norm but sometimes you end up
losing to all the other participants who
are vying for the title so sometimes you
would leave with no money
and minus 20 rating points i've have
been there done that so
again
it's very great that they have this yeah
i'm very glad that there's at least a
little something guaranteed okay let's
look at the im section
total of six thousand dollars first
price twelve hundred dollars last pla
last place four hundred dollars still
the same same concept even if you end up
having a really bad tournament you still
go home with some money and
yeah and um all the prizes
so you've seen the prices up top so you
are motivated even if you are
already having the title or five iron
ones already and uh
not the rating to actually finish on top
actually we have plenty of players with
titles
let's talk about that a little bit okay
first i have to tell you the story so
uh but when i was like 15
i
won the asian youth championship for the
third time and i was like you know what
maybe i could actually be a professional
chess player and think about more
more of chess than just fun
only after the third time winning the
asian youth championship but then i
realized oh wait i won the u
championship for under 16 so i got
one of my 1im norms and i was like hmm
well i got one norm let's see how can i
find good tournaments to get the other
two
and then i started going to more
international tournaments and then i
just got
four four norms in a row and i was like
i only need three man i i mean i got
like i ended up my um i got my wim title
with five norms and two extra and at
that like in the in the late storms i
was like hunting for wgm norms but i was
always like a little bit of raiding
performance shorts or like there was one
tournament that one of my opponents
didn't show up so it was like a eighth
round norm it was like all kind of all
types of complications but i made it i
got the wim title then i worked on the
wgn title then the i am title then the
feta trainer title now the doctor title
if you're looking for more and more
titles there yes and there's only only
one thing that i wanted to add that um
actually my coach said that sometimes
it's better that you don't get the title
meaning
that you gain even more rating points
fair so you're hunting for more you get
even more experience so there's some
benefits to it although
even though at that moment we're kind of
sad like after the sixth iron norm
you're like okay i've been here before
yeah all right let's see whose game do i
want to look at
okay i think i have to start my friend
just because of you know principal let's
go for the on the gabriel gabby's game
gabby with erin so gabby is my current
teammate she's going to be couch surfing
for a few days
in the upcoming actually i think from
tomorrow so i i by principal i have to
take a look at her game she had a really
really nice win the first round
which
what happened there because um i've and
many others were wondering talia too
what happened actually i would love to
get her down here when her game is over
i think it'll be so much fun to actually
ask her about that too i haven't had the
time to catch up with her i know she had
a rough day yesterday but this game
right now
is
yeah it's very wild what's your take so
far uh i took a look at it maybe an hour
or two ago and i was like where was it i
think it was a little bit earlier around
the king was still on b2 and i was just
like holy guacamole what is going on
yeah i think it was around here and like
this king just feels so
i don't want this to be mine
yeah it feels very weak and fragile over
there
and uh like black skins
very unexpected i wouldn't say safe i
kind of want to say unaccessible because
right now it doesn't i mean i feel like
if these pawns are all back where in the
original place i would say safe but
because these pawns have been moved
there's a lot of chances of poking from
white so
right now this king is not very
accessible but this king seems to be so
i'm gonna fast forward to the current
position
yeah this king seems to be really
covered up
this king is whoa yeah it's less safe on
f7 i mean this is one of those theories
that i always like to talk about and
that's
just having guardian pawns in front of
your king and
now
gabby actually chose to protect her king
with knights
and it's actually a good concept a lot
of times you can replace the pawns with
pieces
and in this case it looks pretty good
for her
i know and the one thing i am a little
um concerned about was her time if i'm
not mistaken she had like one minute
where did the time go well if you um
i think this is sinking right now but i
think i yeah it was just a minute
against 11. yeah it's still a little
shaky
although if she survives
the onslaught by aaron i think
she had very reasonable winning chances
yeah
uh also remind me do the players get 30
minutes after 40 moves i believe they
don't
well but i'm not so sure about that
exactly so there's one more thing that i
wanted to add though and for that i will
have to
say goodbye to the little fox
so let's take a look at this position oh
my this position i think fits gabby's
style way more than her previous game
against jennifer u and i'm not really
talking about the result but talking
about
peace placement and the way of playing i
felt that in this game she's playing the
style that she's most comfortable with
being aggressive yeah and i feel that
oftentimes she's just playing
unnecessarily solidly because the
position demands it
and she could go for something more
sharp and even though this isn't really
great for her it fits her style and i
think that's why she managed to turn
this around
because it fits her better better
did you experience that ever that you
play in an opening but if you realize
that hey this is just not my style even
though it's great
it's just not something i'm looking
forward and actually g4 is a great move
here and this is kind of the case in
point
that um gabriella finds this idea of
closing it and being very tactical so
for her i feel that getting sharp
positions is something that she should
be looking forward to because that's
where she excels at but sorry i no no i
was just thinking
if i'm not mistaken she only needs one
more wg
to complete her title so that should be
very exciting for her
and
i remember those days man
so stressful
yeah it is very stressful
and don't
[Applause]
well yeah one minute with 30 seconds
it's not the end of the world so knight
g7 f3 and this little tactical trick so
if you take there's rook g1 yeah and
then you lose one of the bishops skewer
yep so knight g7 f3 and this is what i'm
saying this is her style
using a little cheapos and now i turn
around what do you think about these
specific pawn structure
the center being super close yeah so
white has this extra space in the center
and even though black is solid
that extra space counts just for so much
and um well there are these i'm kind of
borrowing the term from ilia gamblers
who kind of say okay i have less space
and i might get squashed in the long run
but uh i might just check meet you
anyways
so
in general principles
this is obviously better for white yeah
because you have more space but i do
want to come back to the question i
asked you
so were there any openings that you
thought um okay this is good but it's
just not for me
oh we have a result uh yes for me uh
we'll we'll come right back to it but uh
paul meyer
actually won again
wow
from the beginning i agree
so you can just go there yeah
uh
well i
i'm a little impressed by the opening
wall
i'm kind of going to run through it
because i want to see how this will
turn because
you know i always tell my students about
the importance of center
and right now these title players aren't
really doing as much as i tell my
students to do stuff in the center and
so to clarify
it's about control of the center right
now black has a lot of control
in the center and the surrounding
squares so does white right
there's a lot of options there's a lot
of opportunities so that's kind of like
i feel like if white could get e4 it
could be really pretty m or it just did
wonderful
so yeah you're right like once you get
the center by default you get the
advantage yeah yeah perhaps here d5
might have been more
yeah much better our stopping point just
get the foothold in the center yeah
i'm not so sure where is that going
maybe trying to do e5 well yeah that's
actually surprising that uh black goes
for these passive like this knight
maneuver
seems a little dubious to me yeah it
feels too
how do i put it artificial i guess yeah
oh chilled well it's very
chilled but i don't know what that night
it is definitely on vacation of some
sorts
man i need a vacation
all right so black managed to finally
get some center but yeah i think talia
was talking about this earlier that
white has just so much more opportunity
so much more
options so much more control
so much more excitement
yeah i feel like if black could get like
e5 and keep it there safely that would
be nice but i don't see that happening
anytime soon
okay quick question on the knight
nitrate how would you explain this to
someone who wants to understand better
about what to trade when to trade
well you always have to look for what
pieces you can improve
um that night on e6 is that
quintessential don't put that knife
there
peace okay um so you just want to remove
it if you get the chance so i kind of
like this move of knight c7 the other
piece i really hate is this bishop on c8
and
what's funny is that uh at least in my
chess education nobody really talked too
much about that bishop yes in the french
it is extremely terrible
but it's kind of the big problem in any
opening you play as black
did you get any education of the c8
bishop early on in your career no not
really i think that was very early um
that i started to notice it was when i
was reading the the specific book uh
with that prime margin [ __ ] wrote about
how to play against french comic-con and
philidor and the more i read it i was
like oh this makes sense this is really
a weird bishop
so yeah it's just like i started to
notice more of this bishop being
not very good for black when it comes in
french
and i have really good results in french
i'm doing a mini course on it on our
youtube channel feel free to
look into it leave me comments
and
yeah i mean that bishop is just a
problem child like always
the naughty kid and uh so knight c7 is a
great move
the another way you could i think i
could think about it is this night right
now isn't really useful and this night
is so if you trade them off you're kind
of getting rid of one of your un not
really useful pieces and giving it up
for a useful piece of opponent
so it's kind of like an indecent offer
midnight c7 just trying to trade that
terrible one for a good one and it was a
good idea to not take it because if you
take it this queen also here isn't doing
much so then the queen would be
looking at potential weaknesses here so
white did a good job
not taking it c4 was really cool take
take yeah now there there might be some
potential palms terms over here too
oh you you
yeah i'm really liking white right now
and whites ended up winning so yeah yeah
i mean uh and this is kind of the way
you transform an advantage before we saw
a knight on a6 and we said oh you're
better but now it's getting even more
tangible right
like you have those two pawns in the
center before
it wasn't as visible i agree and um if
i'm not mistaken which i don't think i
am uh joshua does have two i am norms he
already has the rating so he just needs
one more so i think
i don't want to jinx it knock on wood he
might be able to do it in this
tournament
he could get his last i am norm here
he's been on the roll like this is his
second win
but of course the tough part comes when
you're playing black
so uh this was two nice wins as white
but we'll see how he's doing
when the
uh turns i have another result too that
i just noticed alice lee just drew with
jennifer you
and i see them walking
do you want to try and get to get them
um well first let's take a look at the
game
um this is like a very newish line
although i actually played this once or
twice back in 2017 and i don't think i
had that great understanding of what i
was doing so i didn't enjoy it as much
but definitely got my opponents thinking
uh what made you play this move though
what's the idea if i'm not mistaken
again it's been a few years that i've
played this it was very trendy back in
i looked at it and i 2016-17 like wow i
know this kid has great openings so let
me look into it a little bit more
and actually that's a great way of
trying to get a bigger repertoire that's
something that i did myself like i did
look at like rock boards here and say
hey
this line is a lot of fun and in fact i
have actually a story of that one um
i was thinking of getting a sharp line
and said okay let's play something in
the
dutch
and i was like hmm now this there's this
guy 25 60 from the 80s and he's winning
all his games in the stonewall so let's
just try that out i thought okay this
guy has the name akdeshtan okay
fun fine and years later i learned that
he was actually the first coach
of magnus carlsen wow
so
unknowingly i was
following where he got this stonewall
ideas
that's very wonderful well that's quite
a lot of fun i imagine i actually see
right now there's been some really um
really high rated players like you know
man for example magnus playing this is
black here and there just saying
casually yeah so this has been played
and is very popular of recent although
even more savage played this i think he
was the first one he was the first
pioneer to play this a6 line and the
point is to take on c4 and then go for
b5 that's why alice lee went for c5 b6
takes kind of which blocking the
opponent yeah just blocking it and again
keeping this bishop locked in so if you
take here yes black is sort of
losing apart from the center but this
bishop gets much more active
so the point of alice lee's move is to
keep this bishop locked in
take stakes
nothing special this is sort of like an
exchange slaw right yep
some trades castles here nothing
spectacular
i really like that light on e5 to be
honest yes that knight is very very good
do you know the name of this mike
i just want to call it honey well yeah
you could call it actually pillsbury
honey okay
because it was harry pillsbury who
played this in hastings millions and
millions of years ago my brother played
the tournament in hasting a few times
because he lives in the uk so he plays a
lot of tournaments there and he sends me
cool pictures
so like he won i think in the 1900s
and uh he kind of died young that's why
he's not that well known but he loved
playing with this
knight on e5 which is over protected and
usually gives a very good advantage now
queen b3 knight c6 is a great move by
jennifer trying to trade off that mighty
knight trades trades here
here rook c7 here here and in this
position actually here i was like
wondering hmm
what would petrossian do in this
position
and uh
and then i said to myself why not rook
c4
oh yeah
i do remember i've seen a lot of like
anytime anybody talked about exchange
sacrifices dispositionally all that's a
lot of petrossian
but it's been a little while since i've
used that
knowledge yes
yeah i mean it's a very very rare
case when the position is similar like
that like takes so even if you bite the
bullet there and i think this feels like
bullet right
you don't wanna i don't wanna be white
right now yeah this is just too
dangerous even if you go here i just go
back
like queen c6
and um i win the pawn back and plus
these pawns might just start rolling yep
so
i'm gonna ask a trick question for you
okay
can you tell me how old is ellis lee
whoa
i think she's around
12 i want to say final bet
yeah i'll go with your correctness oh my
goodness
you almost loved me you almost left me
there i try i try
but
yeah i mean she's been playing amazing
especially in the american cup so far
she's not having a great event and
what's your impression of her if you see
very talented she's definitely very
talented and i feel like uh the the
america is the land of opportunities so
if you have talents and you're here
there will be opportunities
um and i i think i see her i see her
mother around so i know she's you know
she has a great support system support
system is such a huge factor i say this
because i remember when firozo was a kid
because well we were grow up in the same
country and he was in the same age group
as my brother
everywhere he was his father was there
you know always supporting i was behind
you know tournament doors always like
looking for the next opportunity always
just
just supporting i don't know how else to
put it just that that's amazing of a
support so i know that having uh that
great of a support system especially
within your family can take you well
very far and seeing that she has her mom
here with her waiting and you know
um
just being there yeah no i mean it's
very it's not enough actually just to be
talented
um you have to get the experience
and especially for example
carlson like he traveled so much i think
he spent like 80 or 90 of his time when
he was like 13 to 18 to travel all
around the globe and if if he wouldn't
have done that i think he would have
played kasparov or karpov in reykjavik
and it was actually i think the
breakthrough that's when he actually
really became famous when he beat karpov
in that rapid match
and
that that's what we're saying and i
completely agree with you that you need
to have some support or at least
get a lot of experience and playing in
plenty full of events yeah i know so
many talented players who just
wonder one reason or another they didn't
have a supportive country or supportive
chess federation or supportive parents
or you know
they couldn't find good coaches and they
are no longer playing competitively or
they kind of change their dreams so it's
really really important to see that um
saint louis chess club and u.s chess
federation cares this much about these
young towns and i really like that about
it
yeah and what's pretty amazing is that
we have more and more girls playing in
these events like i think this is the
first time
i see this many
ladies and girls playing um
and that's actually a great direction
american cup was great and i really hope
that the karen's cup will return it
would be really fun it was postponed i
believe yes yes so um hopefully you'll
be back soon
looking forward to it so let's take a
quick peek did jennifer actually play
rook c4 no she didn't
but eventually
she did
okay
so
i was very happy to see that
rook c4 knight b8
queen a2 b4
a4 and honestly with that knight gone
black is actually having a free ride to
heaven
a4 a5 b3 bishop a6 getting rid of this
terrible bishop
queen d2 take sticks
rook c2
rook c1 so
i feel that this oh no
getting blundered oh gabby blunder no no
no we're gonna take a look at it
in a moment just let me finish the
thoughts here
um so take stakes rook c2 rook c1
and if jennifer could have gotten her
queen to a6 somehow then she would have
like a big big advantage but ellis lee
is just in time to go and play rook c1
so trades
trades queen c7
and
the game actually peters out in a draw
so let's take a look at gabby's game
versus
aaron
a very very sharp position but there's
one last piece there
so let's see what happened earlier
so we left around here
knight
c7
bishop a5 so far i like what i see yeah
king c3 which is very reasonable you
want to move away
we also have results from the gm section
so let's see what happened in gabby real
quick and move to the replica game okay
so bishop c4 all good bishop h4
oh
man
tactics tactics take take check yeah
take things like gary had him yeah but
look at the clock
and i think that so
even though i feel that gabby had a much
better game today than yesterday
she just didn't have time for the
critical moments
yeah unfortunately this would actually
win yeah she had all her pieces and
right spots and all the tactics right
there
just but the problem is the clock look
at the clock i see she had
one minute versus six and actually gabby
is sort of suffering because of the lack
of time control and she might be a bit
more experienced with that yeah with
more time and uh she just took something
yeah she did take something so that's
fast forward what happened because
taking isn't the mistake i know a2
knight e8
bishop did oh sue
was
she forgot
yeah this is a little confusing probably
shafor got something here
unfortunately for her because that can
be just captured and that's just a free
piece
yeah it could have been time
[Music]
because she only had 39 seconds at that
moment afterwards it's just uh
near losing take sticks just and even
here if she would have found rookie six
there's still some hope but six is i
mean i feel like your k6 is harder to
find especially after you've just
blundered yeah but knight takes the e8
uh like you really don't want to trade
if you're behind material makes your
opponent's life definitely easier
although of course it's easier to talk
when you have all the time in the world
that's also true
so queen e1 queen e7 still trying to
create some opportunities there should
be five takes takes and actually
grabinski is doing the right thing
he's um giving up the piece but for the
exchange of a mating attack
and now uh gabby's in big trouble
she is
ship a4
but um
it's actually
it's actually very painful because even
if black doesn't see any sort of mating
attacks he could just take on f3
yeah
and
yeah i was going to say maybe
maybe aaron needs a norm or two but he's
already
all capped out he already has the im
title so yeah he already has the i am
title but as we said earlier you also
play for the prizes and rating and
rating too yes
he also lives in the texas so it's
giving me some utd
wipes
yeah so i believe he plays for texas
tech
oh
the game is over no actually i'm wrong
utd you're right
yeah and the game is over because after
c4 king takes c4 queen d4
is checkmate
and gabby resigned and
even though this was a heartbreaking
game for gabby i do think that she did
way better and if not for the time
trouble i think she had fair chances to
even win this game
yeah yeah she she definitely had all her
pieces and right spots
you know like rights in the tactics zone
so if you go back to 30 yeah
she definitely had her position set
for
you know like one thing that always
creeps me out personally
uh is like when there is like a bishop
in front of my king in the same diagonal
or like rook in front of my queen you
know those like diagonals or files or
ranks like if i have something that can
potentially attack me in the future i
just want like no i'm out of here like
i'm just going to move the king or block
that diagonal or something
but
and i think that um i mean everyone
deals differently with time trouble i
don't know about you but it could be
that she sort of freaked out like she
could just go let's say and she did take
take
and just try to make some passing moves
and especially when you get all these 30
extra seconds
um
it makes sense not to rush your attack
right because
you make one more move you play let's
taking c2 then rook a2 you're already on
two minutes yeah so i don't know about
you how do you deal with time trouble
man the heart rate goes up you've seen
me play bullet my heart just goes
just and like i need like a minute after
this game is over
like my cardio it's pretty difficult but
sometimes and especially in closed
positions like this
it makes a lot of sense to
just try to make a couple of passing
moves just to gain some time yeah also
the entire amp section is over
so it's um oh no
yeah so we've got the bagging game that
uh finished so let's take a look what
happened and i
so not from the beginning let's take a
quick look at the results first then we
can jump into this game and call it
goods on the im section
um do you wanna
uh yeah let's just go through the
results first yeah so
i believe joshua is in great shape to
knock on wood complete his i am norms
here and get his title
the other ones are
i think it's just a big
up and down mm-hmm so i think if i was a
betting one i would put money on that
but yeah let's take a quick look see who
else has
potential
title slash norm chances what about azer
chambers how do you feel about that any
chance there well he just won a very
nice game against julian
um
i believe that
he made a draw against marac
previously
so
some chances there i don't know about
the previous results though
i know these two results from him
yeah that's totally fair um all right
i think
let's go ahead and
take a quick look at the game game
unless you might have potential
interviews
okay so who are we waiting for no i'm
just i'm just hopeful okay hopeful all
right so we may have either marek or
grabinsky aaron grobinski i was really
hoping for one of the ladies one of the
ladies
if i were you know when i lose i don't i
need like a i don't know yeah a little
bit of a breather yes it's very
difficult because
especially after like a wild game you
need a little
bit of time to
just cool cool yourself exactly so rook
a4 and this is actually what dorsa was
claiming that what about e5 and
it actually came in
my hobby horse
the guardian pawns even though
objectively it's not that bad for
begging but because her king is exposed
there and there's no pawn on f2 it's
much easier to play for black
that's why i always say
if you don't have to don't really move
your pawns in front of your king
it's a good point yeah why to why would
you make opponent happy with potential
targets right yeah the queen d3 takes
takes
wait a second
so bishop takes c5 what mark is trying
to do is get closer
i see that go go one more back for me
queen detroit just felt so
off
what made you feel that way
so many
questions
oh
all right hello so um
we are going to take one final look here
and then we are going to have
our guest in
let's go skip it as a surprise already
yes although i have something that i
want you to ask
the person i'm not even gonna use
pronouns here
uh
what i will be very curious to find out
about his hedgehog with a pawn on e5
what is his secret and why is that good
not good i i want to know about that so
anyways uh let's breeze through here
check
rook takes it ow so that's kind of the
problem um huge well king g3 is scary so
i don't really blame baguem not to play
king g3
because
it feels very dangerous but king e2 was
also not great because it's sort of
running into the line of fire yeah and
after that it sort of quickly collapsed
as even though there's a strong pawn but
it's easily blockaded and now bad game
is very close
to be just straight up losing
and the game ended after rook f2 king c3
queen a1 check pieces got really active
really fast
and
it's one of those things you know you
just
the position looked so cold
like 10 moves ago and there was
no um
huge change happening
except the king got more accessible and
more accessible and yeah the more i look
at it the more i would prefer to be
black right now
and
it's quite unfortunate because i believe
the game has two norms she's on her last
norm hunt
40 i am and
it's proving to be too difficult in this
tournament
all right so we have our surprise guest
in the studio
hello hello how was your game
not very good yeah we were looking at it
and uh well beautiful end whoa very very
nice kingdom
king of the hill uh queen d4 i guess
yeah yes
but
yeah not very smooth for sure yeah so uh
first question when you're talking about
this i couldn't remember
still collegiate chess yes i'm uh i'm
gonna be entering my final year in the
master's program at university of texas
dallas wonderful wonderful yeah we were
talking about utd or
um the other type of yeah
all right uh wonderful so
um
everything seems to be normal and i
believe
danish had a question about the hedgehog
it's not really a hedgehog though right
i don't understand how it's a hedgehog
he said it i'm asking it uh but for a
hedgehog i need b6 a6 and e6 and i still
have a c pawn right
so far you do
okay so this to me looks more like that
variation the names of indian like the
hubner oh where you have a lack of space
on purpose but to me this looks nothing
like a hedgehog
well
maybe i'm just cramped which is also the
true in the hedgehog so maybe there's
some similarities did you expect white
to castle soon or did you yes
i i never dreamed she'd go long here but
that's fair um i mean i guess takes on
a5 is fine maybe
maybe she could also um take uh
ambassador but i'm not sure instead of
ba five oh
so well but on the sun
with the knight it seems potential kind
of okay but if she gets a knight to d5
maybe
could be a could be a long run to dare
yeah so she plays bishop c3 for example
and then
i i'm not really sure how to evaluate
this i guess it's unclear trying to see
would f5s be out of the i can't i can't
but i think it's not really clear who it
favors yet though
because she'll have some central light
squares the knight on d2 is poor but she
can reroute it
if she gets it to d5 i think white has
some chances i wasn't really sure i was
going to go for it anyway but
yeah well all right let's see
so far the game
seems to be and here it felt okay i felt
good here but the computer hates my
position
i was just thinking okay i'm gonna go
night age five play a five
and
i don't really know what she did in the
next two minutes yeah
i wasn't really sure what her plan was i
guess um well i guess her plan was to
delay castling as long as possible and
try to do it
and then
put her other knight on d2
but what are your thoughts on taking
yeah if she takes i take with the pawn
this seemed like a nice
position would you go for e4
soon uh if i can win a piece yes
i guess she'll play but yeah like she
plays wish me too i'll play like
if nothing else i have knight g7 bishop
f6 and then i think this should be nice
with the pawns yeah the e4 is coming
well here does she have 95 i'm not sure
i mean hanging out yeah so maybe i play
niger seven first
and then
also queen eight makes sense yeah and
then maybe e4 but yeah this brings more
pressure to
defense exactly
i do like this position as black since i
play all the weird g6s and
yeah i would play those things okay
no this is this would have been fun um
so let's see yeah because what she did
in the game was probably okay as well
but she came with this very creative
idea of castling wong that was
impressive
so she kind of forced into it maybe but
yeah i was very happy after queen eight
um what i was trying to ask is like um
would you prefer to to keep the tension
or just close up yeah i thought about
keeping the tension but i wasn't really
sure how without playing knight g7
because i want to move my knight on b8
at some point
but she's taking a 5.
and i guess bishop d7s aren't really
doing anything yeah bishop v7 a5 and the
knight on b8 i needed to do something
with it so i really wanted to play
knight d7 but i can't
so i thought well i could play knight g7
and then knight d7 but
i mean i guess that's possible yeah i
just felt like there's nothing really
wrong with f4 it comes with a threat
it will keep the position semi-open
because she can never close it down if
i'm careful well she did later but
yeah at this point i think it's under
control
yeah so queen f7 is that the best move
oh looks pretty good g5 is another
candidate but i think g5s are a little
delicate yeah so you have to be kind of
careful yeah but i thought queen of
seven i mean i of course realized she
could cast along but
i guess i didn't take it as seriously as
i should have turned yeah was also a
surprise
i mean honestly though what else does
she play
it's kind of tough knight p1 i mean that
looks
that looks kind of fake
where would that like go i guess i don't
know but i might already have ideas like
take everything on g3 queen f3 it gets
tricky
yeah this is probably the best move yeah
and
evidently i'm much better now but
i wasn't sure at all
during the game
and i totally botched it at some point
because
yeah why is this so good i don't
understand how our king is weak
well i think it should be weak but it is
but it's really hard to access it yeah
so let's say
i mean g5 is a terrible move it's
logical though it is because i wanted to
just
kind of give her the move
and not really commit to anything
because i felt like it was harder for
white to play this position and i just
wanted a move that kept the tension gave
me kept all my options open
but
i just completely forgot about g4 well
how about take yeah i could take she
takes the f pawn
and then bishop g5 to prevent the g4s
this way your bishop is also in a very
good spot right i guess yeah i
overestimated rook f1 and like a rook
trade i guess that's no big deal so when
you played bishop g5 did you consider g
oh it's that's embarrassing no worries
it was very embarrassing she played it
and i was like oh come on
yeah but if she doesn't have g4 then
bh35 is literally yeah but also taking
is looking uh really scary really this
is playable man
it says it's good for me i i
practically i'm not for sure rook
this is this doesn't feel real whoa
that's cool though
if i get here it's obvious but wow i
didn't see this at all
no we were looking at it and i was also
wondering why is the engine loving it
too much i guess i should have thought
more about taking the pawn but i kind of
dismissed it
i don't think bishop d8 is that um
that human ever move yeah that's tough
to see and it's the only move yeah so
you have to see bishop d8 if you're
giving up completely winning wow yeah
but
yeah that's interesting
yeah
it's gonna be a nice tactic to show to
your students for sure yeah definitely
yeah i guess i'm not that good
yeah and
i mean i think the four maybe five moves
around here now i realize the advantage
is gone because like her king side is
fine now yeah
and i might be worse if i'm not careful
there was one or two spots might be one
yeah it was a very good move
uh i saw it coming i was hoping she
wouldn't find it but she did yeah the
knights getting to b5 was definitely a
good move from gabby yeah and
i think for for the most part right now
it's just things are just happening
because
i don't think either of you have that
clear of a plan yeah but i liked her
position more here
she's my best friend so i kind of have
to root for her yeah but probably hear
you were happy a little bit sorry yeah
no that's totally fine yeah
i was not happy here
because here i thought about g5 but that
looked bad because then
i could never really take the knight on
b5 without losing all the light scores
yeah and that's something that actually
happened then it was so i'm sorry i'm
gonna skip through sure there was a one
moment that i was like oh this should be
so much fun
we're almost there
she's getting she got her bishop here oh
right right because here at this stage i
was getting completely outplayed yes
everything was going wrong
knights on c6 can never get rid of it
but here i don't know what else to play
i have to take 98 oh that looks awful
no i don't really like your position no
no it's terrible yeah but this this here
i was like whoa stuffer yeah she's
winning i totally believe it yeah i feel
terrible
plus eight yeah there was this tactic
and i was like oh i love the special in
front of the king there should be
something in there yeah i saw actually
she can also
because the idea is bishop c7 right yep
and then d6 track yep yeah
yeah that's
it's a bit unfortunate yeah this would
have been fun but hey you had a i think
you had a better start and a better
finish so yeah great job oh thank you uh
i would wish you a happy tournament i
was going to say title but you already
have it
yeah this should be fun but i also was
told that all the games are actually
over
in the
uh gm section as well
maybe not
well
this one is i'm a little confused
waiting on updated title
directory one is coming yeah
but
just waiting on a second so who are you
uh anyone specific you're rooting for in
this tournament
in the gm tournament yeah uh
i guess uh it'd be cool if joshua ruiz
won it kept up his form he's doing quite
well and uh yeah he's a pretty cool guy
so i'd like to see him win
thinking um venezuela
uh i think colombia oh colombia yes yeah
i think uh he lives in texas now yeah i
believe i like i think i met him in like
2014 world youth championship because
i'm one of my best friends paola
rodriguez she is i've played her once
yeah yeah she i believe like she's
married to gm
boy i i don't have enough chests okay
that's why
yeah
uh but her teammates are you were saying
was he her teammate maybe
bruce uh yeah
because she's colombian yeah i think i
believe so um okay i think uh ben can
you repeat that for me
uh my last game yeah i guess my last
game i was white i guess dennis hasn't
which left
i need
[Music]
oh yes no uh dennis you're correct yeah
but that was a hedgehog if i can and i
had the lack of space but that was i
think that was pretty difficult
two round two i was playing with black
and yeah that that was that was a
hedgehog
but i think if you go just a few moves
you'll see the i think the position is
quite different than my game with
gabriella right this is a hedgehog yeah
pawn structure is
much more
fluid oh okay i see your point danish i
did have to play e5 yes
ah yes okay um so yeah it's more similar
than i thought i guess i didn't want to
play e5 oh but i had to kind of maybe i
didn't but uh e5 was a threat and i
thought he wants to play e5 so i play 85
and yeah it's kind of a bad hedgehog now
well yeah
uh i wish you the best of luck for the
remaining well thank you uh
got two double rounds yeah some of the
next two days
enjoy thank you very much
wonderful i believe next we're gonna
have
we have another interview coming up
right
all right i'm gonna keep it as a
surprise because i just love the
suspense
okay so put your bets in
thank you of course
all right let's see
today's game
a lot of fun
all right
hello how's it going wonderful how about
you
enjoying the thunders
yeah yep definitely
all right
we have
trying to remember if i can
yeah
i'm sorry i was trying to come up with a
smart way to say something about title
or norm like i lost it i'm just going
with is a chamber normally how's it
doing yeah sorry so how is it how does
it feel um
poor poor julian yeah poor guy i mean uh
i think he was kind of unlucky
yeah definitely he's um he's one of the
uh club employees so he's teacher
teaching and always
very uh active so i'm
i know him better okay can you sorry yes
but so how was this game how did this go
something that's yeah i didn't prepare
against this it was 50 i was 50 50 that
i was going to do
this or um
or
e5 so i prepared against e5 but then he
goes carl khan fair right and uh
yeah and i saw this idea a couple years
ago a friend of mine
mentioned it briefly and that's good
enough for me
so
i went knight d2 and then knight b3 yeah
huh
and i i saw this idea of bishop b5 check
that's basically
the depth of the appropriation yeah
exactly nice
yes
so then knight c6
and
yeah take yeah take take and then this
yeah and the plan is to have some sort
of dark square blockade
but this bishop you know i i'm quite
happy with the
the way black's bishop is placed
yeah after i played bishop e3 i thought
maybe 92 is more precise first to get
this knights rolling right and also i
have b4 with my c3 pawn protected yeah
um
yeah maybe it makes sense yeah that i
mean i feel like if you could get that
and i have a bishop on stefa i would
definitely like white a lot more right
ideally the bishop goes to c5 and then
knight d4 yeah and then it's really good
but i don't know if that's actually
that's easy to achieve because yeah yeah
julian is blocking it
yeah yeah he is and uh i think i have to
go bishop
c5 it's the most logical move i i have
to agree because i feel like anything
else and
i mean this seems to be really
problematic even if queen d2 yeah that's
weird are you still gonna have to try
and do these right and even if you get
that knights to d4 still what are you
gonna do with your kings that's a good
point um
i was singing a4 instead of queen d2 but
i don't know i think yeah i don't think
i'm really in time
okay let's say queen d3 how do you feel
about queen traits i probably have to
take
and yeah maybe oh wow okay
that's nice i was i was just gonna play
92 but king d2 first i mean wins the
tempo so
a lot of stuff yeah it does stuff have
to look very interesting the thing is i
have this a pawn it's very dangerous
like a game take on a5 sometimes yeah
and pass pawn yeah this could be
definitely
really fun for you so
that's it's good to know you got your
game stuff covered
so okay bishop c5
oh nice yeah oh i think i have to
otherwise
92 bishop d3 how is it king d2 wow i
would i didn't like this i thought this
wasn't good yeah
king d2 yeah i don't i mean i feel like
between comparing this position to just
exchanging queens you made the right
choice to go for the queen trade yeah
and i didn't even consider uh king d2
let's just
yeah no
all right so queen trained
wow a4 is that bad
a4 definitely feels like giving giving a
lot of opportunity
because
this could easily become a
very very nice target for you to go
after
yeah but on the other hand
um is that or giving me a outside pass
pawn yeah but i feel like even if that
happens this knight could get activated
faster
compared to when there's on a4 the
bishop on c5 is really killer i don't
want to see much future for this knight
no
oh i was thinking maybe f6 96 to f7 at
some point would be the future
okay but even in that space still this
is
this for some reason
i'm
i'm very happy about this a4 and it's
not just because it has these two marks
uh i do like a4
for uh for you because yeah it's a clear
target yeah king d2 because otherwise
bishop d3
well maybe take take then at some point
maybe rook and forth just block it and
then if that becomes
let's say we get the knight out
uh king d2 i think here okay
let's say keep getting the pieces out in
92. let's say just bring in a rock and
now you're way better
it just feels faster it just feels like
you need to activate the pieces faster
than
you can maybe you have to go bishop d6
to stop broke b at some point
like here bishop d6 maybe this is
this might be a nice way for black to
activate their knight and you can double
rook a6 and now it's a weakness
interesting okay yeah
i agree that this this is a outside
passport and it could be interesting for
you but i feel like this way black can
be very very fast getting the pieces out
so
hmm
but it's definitely a hard decision to
make
all right
i like that this is you're bringing all
the pieces where they need to go nice
nice
yeah um
yeah this is bad
well not for you no no but yeah
i'm really active in a3s exactly yeah
very clear targets for you to go after
i thought i was being really uh
like smooth with bishop b6 but i don't
know anymore how about take
uh work takes
yeah and then uh
work behavior that's right and they're
really active here yeah
so yeah i agree this would definitely
give opponents with d6 i don't think
king e7 is nothing yeah even king e8
honestly
still this is under attack right
but yeah i feel like this would
definitely give opponents more happiness
than just bishop b6
i don't know how i feel about just you
know changing gears here
i don't know
but even if they ignore it like
and then am i really threatening like h5
here
would you well one bishop g6 9.4 n94
okay missed that as long as the knight
f4 is there right also like even if they
trap their rock how can they eat it
all their pieces are too far away from
yep but the thing is like i thought if
yeah no there's no targets even yeah no
it's a good point thank you thank you
but bishop b6 i'm not against it i do
feel like changing gears is a little um
my idea is to go yes sorry my dear so if
i go rook a3 here there you go knight b5
and yeah oh yeah so my idea of bishop b6
was to be able to go bishop a5 in this
position so if your bishop was on b6 you
would just bring it and then a4 exactly
yeah that was that was a nice sketch
all right
let's see
yeah and rook a6 i saw was bad but
apparently yeah he told me also there's
a move here so yeah this strip costs to
be activated man
and i think yeah i still stack the
exchange but
i don't know
why not bishop a5
yeah that's right and he told me yeah
that's right he saw the computer said
bishop b1 after the game
yeah
never
i don't think anyone would find that
really we were just looking at a
different position
different game uh with aaron and oh my
god
there were so many like nice computer
moves that i was like that's he was even
like surprised that's that's the thing
yeah so this feels like that too yeah i
don't think there should be one i mean
it's i feel like if you're actively
looking for weird moves you might find
out
but
normal chess practical chess it's a
little harder to
come up with bishop b1 ideas although
this pawn here might might make things
more interesting and give some
opportunities too but yeah i agree there
should be one definitely not an easy
move to find
all right nice sacrifice
wonderful i like this pawn
yeah near yeah it's winning it's just
yeah it's just super comfortable and
this guy is also
right and i just eventually went upon
and yeah
now you got the past one that you wanted
activating the knight nice technique
also really important for the viewers
out there to know their pawn end games
because you got to know this is you're
going to be able to win this and i have
so many students who can always benefit
from improving their own opponent games
ooh
nice nice shot
thank you i think at this point you're
just showing off with mine before and
four is so super normal yeah but i mean
maybe even this
but 94 definitely fancy getting on light
in a good spot another another show-off
move nice
they can't take it yes oh
and man this was brutal for julian
yep yeah and then now it's just yeah
did you get the queen i really wish you
no i didn't yeah you ate almost every
other pond so yes well good job
what are your hopes and dreams for this
tournament
i mean i still hope to get a norm i
don't know if it's realistic
but it's never too late so i mean it's
not
i'm gonna retract that
sometimes it is too late but there's a
lot of hope so it's not impossible
we are definitely rooting for you thank
you and
yes
let's jump into results everybody
all right so
let's take a quick look at our gm
section
uh
i believe the last time we're looking at
the results
uh
bose had drawn
and
we did have that
one
juicy win as well but we do have three
new results so i'm not mistaken since
the last time we looked
and guess who's back everybody surprise
uh yeah yeah
so uh plenty of black wins today right
with balaji shitko and victor martian
winning and chris repco the only one
trying to counterbalance
that uh black
three wins
and actually i had a little talk with
gabby
yeah so
she said that uh she was considering
making some waiting moves but
aaron offered to draw and that
that's why you have secret conversations
that i can bring here so you hear you
get the scoop over here um
so
that's when she she sort of got
surprised
but uh again i felt that it was mostly
her handling of time
that was her undoing
probably she needs to be a bit more
careful with that and
try to get like five ten minutes for the
last part i agree um but of course it's
easier said than done
um
like he always gets into time trouble
even though he knows he shouldn't be
yeah um all right anybody in the gm
section that you want to talk about
actually let's just move on to the i am
section
we already i think today we spent so
much time and energy with the
im
section i'm not ready to move on just
yet so any surprising results for you
um
it's still very impressive that postuma
won again
um and i think that he's gonna have a
good tournament and if he keeps on
rolling he
might finish up top um ezra chambers had
a very nice game uh you just looked at
it and knight t4 was very impressive
um and overall he was very technical and
i really liked that
wonderful yeah i think this was
definitely a
i wasn't very happy with the gabby and
big game losing but oh you want to know
a tiny fun fact tell me uh begins uh
full name gold rock begin so gold rock
which has persian
meaning so gold roch is face
although it's also called the rock chess
rock
you learn
every day
i think she uses just begin at this
point but i still that's her middle name
actually or i think probably i don't
think in in in that part of the world we
have middle names it's more of a
long name
it's just a longer name honoring a
family or a longer part of the okay yeah
but yeah so we're kind of in between
rounds right now
so so let's take a look at standings if
we have them
we could also play some viewers that is
true
so we will be here that we don't have
standings for the moment but uh the
rounds are going to continue when are
they going to continue if
five o'clock
so
the event is going to continue on five
o'clock and um the
uh commentary will resume i think
tomorrow at two like same time same
place although uh if i'm not
i believe that harrison will be doing
some coverage on our twitch channel for
this evening yeah but we are not done
yet though yes we are here until four
but hair zone will start right after us
yes so tune in for twitch but for now
feel free to go and challenge us to some
some games if you want right yeah so
we're just doing a switch here we have
the games finished right now we're going
to play some games and now we're going
to yes not for norms
but we are very much happy to take on
you guys
yes tris you want to send us a challenge
and tracy left the building
is magical today
scaring people off man i graduated twice
in the last 24 hours
it's been
very eventful
there's i never knew there's a
pre-commencement that you get down you
get to do the walk down the i'll
actually sorry that's different walking
off the stage on the stage so many
different things and i couldn't remember
the graduation song so every time i've
been talking to people i would just go
[Music]
well you know if there's
pre-commencement there might be a post
commencement oh
i know there was commencement to to this
morning and i was i had to be there at 8
00 a.m or go to the circles at gic
probably i'm trying to cover a little
bit i had a red bull tea dennis brought
some damn sorry danish brought some
chocolates oh god okay we're getting
some challenges so one thing that i have
to add there and sorry to interrupt
no casuals we are serious people
no casuals oh also please give me
increments if you don't give me
increments you'll have to play dennis if
you give me increments do you get to
play me so oh that's
tracy is crazy
so let's see how danish and dorsa will
do against tracy two against one a yes
sure which one do you want to be you
already have that i already have the
mouse okay
all right the pawn
i hear tracy screaming from outside
really yes tracy come on tracy find the
right move here no
ah
knight
i won't say queen so
queen well sorry there's no center
square no
uh pawn ah bishop fish
yeah i'm feeling kind of bishopy right
now
bishopy bishop he feels yes
so how long have you been playing the
nimso
let's see i had a
really really bad loss
in queens gambit a few years back and
after that i was like you know what
bye-bye queen's game but i need to break
from you
uh pawn
so
i went i took a long extended break from
queen's gambit that's black and i was
like okay let's just go how see how see
um
circle around the nimzo a little that it
worked nice
no you've been together ever since
so ten years coming up it's a good
relationship between dorsa and enzo yeah
i also really
loved the nimzovich book of my system
wow something you shouldn't have said
because yasir is going to be after you
now but it's okay it's okay don't tell
yes don't tell us it's okay i'm bored
this is actually very interesting what
uh
tracy did i know pawn pawn okay let's go
pawn
wow and that's actually your style you
like to mix classical bit aggressive
and also typical plan
sort of giving up like a side pawn for a
center one
it's like you read my mind also what
happened to our rating did i do that
well there was a french person and uh
i'm not gonna continue
well french
french person
manning the saint louis chess love
account
you know in the sailors chess club there
are grand masters in residence
uh playing and uh sometimes they're
french and sometimes they're not ah yes
for some reason i thought you were
talking about the poor croissant and i
was like oh no no it's not croissant
let's not blame foxes here
well we got a flag we first have to make
a move pink but but fox king yes but
also fox
right if i this would be a twitch stream
probably we'd have king e7
come here good foxy hello beautiful
you've been missed there you are
all right so tell us a little bit about
the position because i'm confused why
are we so happy with what we have not
really not really i'm just happy because
it's been such a great week oh okay
all right so i'm misunderstanding the
situation definitely okay
it's not the point she wanted
i wish i could put my pawn on e4
e4 they'll take it i know but well i
you know we could actually play
a game of bishop crazy house
we'll need someone's challenges that is
true so if you feel like playing us
send some challenges
it's sweet
for the longest time i'd had no idea who
slash what is stewie
and i started watching a little bit of
the family guy
and not right now oh my god
i can't stop all right well bishop okay
i think i didn't say bishop you would
have
my poor bishop what are you doing to
that poor guy
i thought you loved bishops not really i
like foxes and cats and red pandas rat
pandas
not badgers
you're a badger
i need a picture of a cute badger before
i can make a final drawing
okay that sounds you're not against
badgers after all
i just need more pictures more
information
all right
hmm pawn
one thing i learned from my minor in
healthcare ticks is if you're unsure
about how to answer always say more
information
more information
or you do the grand masturbate and you
say interesting
that's that's too obvious too obvious
okay
what did the french resident do it's
something that we're not talking about
zoram it's something we're not talking
about are you a little anti-french
because you're stuck no i'm only
anti-french when it comes to chess
because i really hate my bishop on c8
being close that's fair oh there
actually tracy is putting our bishop our
french
bishop in jeopardy
night
knight
you do that with the light are you just
playing it
playing okay
well what's the light
what's the light
well
i'm talking turkish tonight
turkish delight here
fun actually not so happy because i
think
it's nice we have a fox defending the
king the fox yeah the fox on f6 but uh
that king
right
guess what is fox and farsi
i have no idea just take a guess i i
can't even guess ruba ruba
there's a hair at the end
um
it's not too far actually from hungary
it's it's far of course pawn it's called
rooka
oh
so um
it's not that far actually oh that was
not pawn
that's okay
you confused me you could i i was
distracted by this to be fair we could
call it you know all pawns have
potential to become queen that's true
there is some logic there okay i'm gonna
go ahead and say
bishop followed by pawn
or
or
you can only choose one okay
you wanted this
[Music]
which surprisingly pia that also means
um when you're just walking on foot
yeah yeah dialogue i mean
it's funny because in hungarian we do
the same like in the sense it means
walker
in hungarian too like it it what you're
saying it would mean that piada is also
walker huh like walking huh
well
walk walker white walker
blackwalker
all right let's stick with the pawn i
assume
oh wonderful
so it takes night a4
i'm a little hungry but
i'm gonna go ahead and um say
queen
again actually not but
oh well
it's the first time you said queen
queen in farsi is
also actually ah surprisingly it should
be malike
it's literally queen
but bazir is like yeah it's the
commander or it's prime minister or
something
yeah easter oh our time we might
actually lose okay put your hand on the
thing
say something quickly tonight all right
let's go here
just jump closer to okay
foxy you gotta go for a second
wait
whoa queen v3 loving that
pawn
pawn
okay
push push push i'll try
yeah actually vasir is the same
bishop bishop okay
you said 33 seconds it's enough no tell
me uh night
night okay
[Music]
ah let's do this
[Music]
okay
then what i don't know maybe queen maybe
queen every night
queen or night
that's a new wait that's starting to
sound a lot like uh yasser's eagle queen
i mean real quick
okay queen
okay
it's okay it's okay
queen then pawn
pawn pawn
it's 20 seconds it's a lot
queen
whoa
whoa
and an angry opponent on the other side
and uh yeah
we want zero writing we won exactly zero
rating and the way we played i think we
deserve that zero rate that is so not
fair too damned and i don't even have
that's not that's actually wrong because
uh tracy you played very very well thank
you do you want to be interviewed
sure i'll talk about it
let's talk about it all right
all right tracy come on in here oh boy
so let's review this game let's not
review this game
oh
so tracy i'm gonna give you the mouse
and you're gonna talk to me about what
what's wrong everything
tell me
what
come on trace you can do it
i need to go to therapy after this we i
also need to go but i don't think we
should see the same therapist
all right let's see
two gm's in it yeah
that would never happen again let me get
some fun let me get some help here
okay everything seems to be normal here
why
yeah we should have a five dash i i
don't like bishop a5 i wanted to get rid
of it
yeah
e4 was better tracy
power center man
so what are your hopes and dreams for
this game to just to just to not get
mated that was the whole plan
really see are you going to do are you
going to blow raspberries yeah
because i kind of want to all right
so far so good yeah queen b3 was a
little
i also wanted to do this potentially or
this
but
the app here is starting to look niche
i liked what you were doing here i did
not oh my gosh just the discoverer
attack no
that's the worst kind yeah e4 i was
trying to decide if you want to take it
or is there anything else probably would
have taken it
good job tracy thank you thank you so
have a nice stream enjoy the rest of
your i will because i'm going to go in
there and cry i cannot believe i just
lost the two gm's that sucks
have some red bull really bad
well
how is everybody doing
i'm gonna see
when will
let me adjust this poor porky over here
there he goes
maybe i should start bringing my red
panda your red panda you have red pandas
just as just
something like this
something like that well yeah i feel
that we lost the viewer now so
good job for us oh i don't think we did
um
and with that the last challenge we had
there disappeared
in a big fear yes where is our child um
yeah they just don't they just don't
dare i'm gonna do something oh no
it's gonna be the bullet game i guess
all right let's go
bye
i'll just commentate
all right sados is taking some space
weird noises
i'm going to be making weird noises
weird noises
yes i mean those are words dorsa i'm
trying to not talk okay so queen e2
interesting play interesting play the
bishop was hanging
i don't feel interesting right now and
uh h4 the knight is trying to undevelop
i'm not sure about that oh but okay so
it was
sort of
wait where am i going with that g5 i
actually have no idea what i'm doing
with that night so a little bit of
majority for black on the queen side but
it's still a fight
i kind of want to queen d3 dors is
feeling the heat
what heat man no more heat she's on the
roll
let f4
like this spirit h6
let's just push him
she's pushing it
let's just push pushing it again
she's a pusher let's push him too she's
a pusher
uh boom boom shakalaka she said
i think i'm running out of pawn to be
honest
well the question is if you have an
attack oh but she has a queen yeah
and 22 seconds for dorsa 23 for the
opponent
don't don't stress me
ooh i blundered
i forgot about it never
give up
i forgot about that
oh that pawn sadly there's a lot of
pieces for black as far as i see
oh but at least she won the king of the
hill
ah
let's see oh
that's actually a nice mate let's give
it that i do i think that you were
obviously winning i like that push push
party yeah that push part i think was
pretty good i wonder if that was best
well if you go back you just go back a
little bit
um go back yeah back back back just
let's see
g6
you could also maybe go e5 immediately
so take six and go e5 yeah and do the
same thing with e5 and d6 yeah
but i think even in the game after your
opponent played g king g7 it worked like
e5
takes
no the computer doesn't knight takes
rook takes
that's interesting
so your opponent's position is so
compact they're not even better here
that's surprising probably had to take
on g4 and i trust that you would have
won this game i don't trust that well
okay if you're playing against the
computer i don't trust anything
but uh i think in a practical game if
you take on g4 i felt you played it well
like your idea was thematic but probably
had to play e5 first too many points
well i just a nice push push again go
again yes
again again
oh we got a 3-1 all right
okay
21-22 we can redeem
our previous gm and res we can gain some
points
ah no kings gambit except oh scotch time
yeah i've seen that you've been playing
scotch it's five all your gm
reds time yup
e5
yeah this knight defend i'm so surprised
that people
just avoid or forget queen e7 but this
is
usually very pleasant for white
usually being the key word
no i don't see well what's the reason
for concern
i want a quick check mate man
we all want quick checkmate that's why
we played this game i heard
i heard that
oh we've got another challenge might be
tracy um no it's not tracy
it's a shame separate yeah yeah
all right
you know what
feeling spicy
but how spicy this spicy
ah
so she wants
i told you i
that's true that's true
you're being very transparent here thank
you to give you that thank you
f5 whoa
pushing a guardian pawn
very naughty very naughty play
by black
i mean
there's so many things i want to do
let's just go for this
just because um
why why explain explain why name please
explain ah
well that's not what i thought why did
you go over
seven mm-hmm ah okay if bishop to ac3
upon it also have clean take c5 ideas
very hungry i don't know what to eat
yeah there's a lot to eat here though
decisions decisions
okay let's start with this
separate saying why is man once said if
you see a fast man in one it starts with
this whoa there was no written one no no
that's not what he said okay
nothing if you see a mate in one always
look for better
wise words i agree supper
whoa
i thought you're hungry that was a juicy
pawn on c6 no i kind of filled up i saw
potential checks ah okay
just being a little bit more
i had a casual good one
so last night after graduation i went to
red lobster for the first time
wow
there's so much
i'd like to say interesting choice but
red lobster is red lobster
it was a red lobster
okay i don't feel generous
you're most welcome says supper i'm here
to spread the old wisdom good good we
need that wisdom
okay i'm feeling a little generous
wow that's a lot of
a lot of generosity spread just a little
bit just a little bit
hello
hello
stay good night so can you tell me your
plans over here i just want to with your
night
oh you just want to get stuff okay
there's no real plan i just wanna eat
stuff
well
eating is a plan
by in itself although
sometimes happens sometimes not on the
chess board
okay let's put this girl over here
let's put
this gentleman up there
let's say move this
good boy
so we've got a dog on e4
we've got
a horse
and a kamikaze rook on f6
not to mention
that other guy on h4
i wanted to eat stuff
no aren't you thank you wow we got two
points yay
you got that extra two points two more
than what we actually have lost
previously
whoa stewie is back for revenge
960.
let's go tracy
960 games so how would you rank
your variants what is your favorite and
what's your least favorite barrier
favorite is queen of the hill
my least favorite is atomic just because
i can't for the life of me play it and
when it's i thought it was horde
no i kind of warmed up too hard
and what is your lifetime experience
with the 960 did you ever play
competitively
i've been thinking about it to be honest
dennis
it's been a
tough few months
i've been hoping to get out there and
play more
960 chess but
for some reason
nah
also there are not many 960 events just
saying
are there any i mean there were a couple
in reykjavik
and somewhere in germany but
that has been a long time ago already
that's fair
how's this good
boy hello is this 960 yep yes this is
960. if it wasn't i would have been
surprised honestly
patrick daley good to see you in the
chatterino see what she's trying to do
that is not a treat
tracy tracy knows her stuff
she castles probably she's been watching
what no
so the way you no no
i'm kidding
actually maybe not
but does she need to move the stroke
tonight
yeah i'm sorry people i i don't know
what to say now because
yeah the dorsal is turning on her evil
mode
so
everyone be very careful
no no just a little careful
just a little bit careful you can't be
very careful
anyways uh bishop g4
i just wanted to that's a very mean move
thank you which kind of
that's that's her mode
so
mainly just 7 30 today it's the best
time to wake up i mean 6 30 is better
well the problem was that i couldn't
sleep well because my cat was singing
all night because there was a stray cat
behind the door
just when my cat was just meow meow mom
come feed
stop
the
cat
mom
adopt the cat i don't know
i thought you're reading into it a
little bit
and it was a really cute cat and i
thought about you know i left some food
out for the little
thing i don't know if it's a girl or
guys i have to little think i'll see can
i casto yeah yo i can castle nice
sorry tracy i tried to trick you about
my castling
so anyways
wasn't there like a big storm yesterday
like it was where i was it was pouring
and crazy
she wants a friend b she wants a lot of
friends
whoa knight c5 let's go tracy
that's a very good move
very good move
check give it up for tracy
you're trying to start a hype train so
you got a new cat nah i think she's a
bit secretive about that
we don't know for sure no no no i
couldn't get a new cat because
unfortunately
um
i'm moving soon to mizzou
so
i couldn't really i can't really deal
with a new cat
also
adoption deferred i have been concerned
about fostering fostering animals i
think it's so sweet
and they get a nice home for a few
months if i actually bond with one and
peachy ends up loving one sure we'll get
a new kid
i mean cat
kit cat no kid
cat
we'll get a new kitkat
oh
that makes me hungry
um
i'm kind of sad that uh
i was
very happy that tracy's flavored queen
after i'm like
not so sure about it i'm happy about it
of course you are
huh
so actually you're not that mean after
all i would have taken with the pawn
just to get an open file i know i might
have to do d4 later
wow
i didn't think about
that
that thank you tracy i've had a really
hard last 24 hours so thank you for
making it better
oh my goodness
cheap shot man cheap shot
you know what
i accept your cheap shots okay so
there's a bit of back and forth and a
bit of dono from dorsa as well
i thought you're donating what happened
i changed my mind
same with donations
sometimes i love them sometimes i
don't know what to do with them
i'm pretty sure that people know what
they would do with donation
support other people or foundations such
as the st louis chess club
it's um no it's not profit so
yeah
because that helps other kids and the
community
learn
that chess game yeah
and and
because of san francisco i got a full
ride to college at slo
hopefully something at mizzou
so
yeah
i'm definitely grateful if there was no
saint louis chess club i wouldn't have
the
come to us for college
g5
so by the way i was wondering
um you haven't been playing much chess
but
are you a fan of i mean i know your take
on bullet but do you like these quicker
ones such as rapid or
blitz
uh anything i have increment i'm good
if no increment no dorsa
interesting
myself i kind of like rapid
sort of in between
and actually we saw
this young
killing it
like this grand chess tour in the
morning
to be honest i have yet to catch up on
this morning because
i was
well
graduating yeah yeah
i had a very big rope and hat to keep on
which is really hard
now you you've got to coordinate
so it doesn't fall
so good take c3
and it seems like dorsa is turning
turning for the collector mode
to play i prefer rapids sly at the top
to watch let's see um
how can i like wrap it because the
rabbit likes me so
it's sort of a mutual thing
for the blitz tomorrow
i'm not promising
the insolence dorsa what is that casual
how dare you say that but i wanted to
sit so i'm going to do it
six minutes left all right all right
let's see who do you want do you want to
no oh it's persian we got okay oh wait
where'd you go
all right
do you want to do it
uh pleasure
okay you sure um no but it's okay
crystal spam all right so
let's what would doritos play
scandinavian yeah that's not what joseph
would play but okay d5
let's play the portuguese
portuguese
yeah it's i've never been to portugal
but i've been to barcelona one of my
favorite places actually
c4 um
let's go here
potentially nights next night next okay
so i changed my mind
all right so if you could choose a place
portugal or
spain spain
why
i stayed there longer no okay i was i
also got sick when i was in portugal not
fondest of memories i see all right
let's go night
over here obviously there's no ticks
well now
i'll go sharp because we like sharp
chests
over here
dorset doesn't like donating but i'm in
a donating mood look i'm stingy with my
pieces
but you'll see you'll see they'll be fun
they'll be fun to be had
yep and we go here bishop d6
i know you want that but now i don't
know if that is possible are you fine
well it takes takes e5
yeah
[Music]
you'll see i have dreams i mean i can
hope crush hopes and dreams but
think about getting some dreams that's
my dream i want queen h1 you can go for
your dream right now i'll go for my
dream
uh go for my own
i think i know what you mean
the french play the french
is the dorsa opening
what's the dorsal opening
anti-french anti-fracture okay okay
we didn't reject you you rejected
playing a rated game
all right
your rokus seems to be a little
funky
thank you
mistake stuff
steak steak steak
higher every night
see i told you even though we gave up a
piece
you're sort of jumping around up and
down like a clown
you're getting funky
[Music]
pawn
[Music]
that was like a question mark question
mark pawn
but okay more pawn
more fun
last rock
night
night
okay so you're listing all the pieces
not queen all right choose between night
or brook all right so that's play night
let's
let's go here
let's i've seen better moments before
but uh
so many ponds so many pawns for us yeah
okay well maybe maybe not enough but
it's a lot pond broke queen
pawn rook queen all right i'll make a
pump
i'm giving you options
that's that's very nice of you let's go
rook d4
i want to trade no
i know you're a bit but just count them
pawns we've got a couple
so
it's not great i admit that but
i'm fine with this
nowhere near their level
um
v
yeah god queen
queen okay let's take ah
are you afraid of knights yes they're
scary
they're scared of humans
you like clowns no i say the knights
look like clowns ah okay rock
rock okay
you wanted this snark
i'll take that one sorry i'm not gonna
take this one now pawn or kink up to you
um
let's go palm
pawn king or rock
you choose one
no no no
well yes yes yes you got to do something
all right let's go here
let's go there
stick
drunk
all right let's go here
drunk
i need to bring the king it's time to
bring the king it's an ending so
king
marking and the big king is walking
just go uh yeah here
just take away that
keep that maybe push
push push push push push
let me push the other side the other
side is well okay look
we're just going for that guy more palms
more rock more pawn more rock
push push push
push push push
let's go here just go
behind
and still it's getting actually
complicated so even though we're down a
piece
we still have two pawns
not the pawn i want
but that's okay more palm more pawn i
don't know which one is good where it is
more palm more pawn watching
okay
you're coming
we're coming to get you
assume pawn
that's fair
so your next choices will be between
pawn rocking king
okay that's fair let's go f3
so look at that those pawns are actually
getting kind of mighty and the king is
calling the car is looking interesting
too
maybe rook b1 then b4 okay
maybe now this is your command
more pawn more pong
pong pong
well played but at the end the pawns
took over
the black marchers took over and
i believe that is it for us right now
but there'll be more coverage in about
an hour
and youtube
yeah
by harrison kaiser yep and uh be sure to
tune in don't go anywhere actually go
take a tiny break and be back soon
yeah and we are going to continue
so the gm norm congress the coverage is
going to continue tomorrow and
see us commentators in the future
all right everybody bye
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you